a very serious escalation of disorganize
whole outside burning Street
Metropolitan Police have just brought in
mind two episodes we've just mounted a
charge time right now from the world
memorial
I don't allege the senator you can see
one of the officers have been milked of
his betters and other objects being
thrown up the mounted officers there and
Whitehall itself to the side of
Whitehall in Downing Street the other
police officers who are regarding the
front of Downing Street have gone into
full white kit and have brought their
white shields out as well you can see in
fact another line of public order
trained officers they're in full riot
gear a charge
Whitehall to push the crowds really
happened and about 20 minutes or so ago
it started to get very wet here were
torrential rain and thunderstorms and at
that point the crowd really turned they
started throwing petals and other
objects and the officers who were
outside the front of Downing Street
they then retreated inside Downing
Street I to be replaced by those
officers in more protection we've just
come out now and of course you can see
the other officers here on Whitehall and
the the officers fought their down still
and forth back we don't know what is
happening sue not mine to officer who
clearly fell off his horse I don't know
if he's been injured because I can't see
that from this point of view
now the protesters right at the front
towards those officers really adopting a
familiar pose that you've seen in the US
where they're getting on their means
putting their hands up we're seeing doom
shoots and I can't
but the police mission furthers
nonetheless determined to move them now
to avoid her they were happy to leave
them here while the protests were
peaceful when neighbors protests turned
violent